so my name is bailey hayes and i am a
principal software engineer at single
store
and today i'm going to give you a bird's
eye view of the webassembly landscape
but first we're going to do a little
brief history
so it's 2012
and i realized that i have a need for
wasm but wasm doesn't exist yet we have
a very large code base that's a data
visualization library but
and we've already found a way to take
portable c plus plus code and run it in
a number of different clients both
in desktop environments and in mobile
and now we want to find a way to do that
with the web
and that's where we enter with what i
believe is the greatest hack of all time
it's my opinion but
if you guys have other great hacks
please tweet them at me because i want
to know but
personally i think asm.js
which is a subset of javascript
and around this time was pushed forward
by alone zakai and other mozilla
engineers and it let us take c-plus plus
and basically transpile it to a little
bit of javascript and be able to run
that in the web
and that really started an evolution
it wasn't perfect um so if i'm going to
pick on somebody else for the greatest
hack of all time i have to give one of
the ones that i put into production and
that was this uh try catch finally block
i was actually
an intern i was working with at the time
added finally at the end and this was
the last thing that made our code work
in ie because we were running out of
memory trying to jit our asm.js and so
this kind of forced it into an
interpreted mode so hacks all around
so
with azim js
we proved a point that there was a need
there was more than just games that were
interested in running real code in the
web
computationally intensive code in the
web and
that's when a number of the browser and
vendors got together and pushed forward
a specification webassembly and uh that
design phase started in 2015 basically
the moment it was available in any
browser we began compiling to it with a
tool called ms scriptin
and you know by 2019 it's a recommended
web standard and officially the fourth
language of the web
now we're all here at wasmday so i
assume that you know a little bit about
webassembly but just in case you're not
lost for the rest of the day
i'll give you a quick definition and the
way that i think of it is that
webassembly is a compilation target
it's portable it's language agnostic
but more than anything
we always have running jokes here at
these different conferences and uh for
the rest of the week you're going to
hear jokes about yaml because of
kubernetes and so i have to say this
it's webassembly is neither web nor
assembly even in 2015 we knew that we
were targeting something that wasn't
just for browsers uh that's really
surprising to people given the name um
and uh
i would say that
around that time we didn't quite have
the term cloud native i actually looked
it up and wikipedia in 2019 was when
cloud native became like you know kind
of a more common term uh the the the
cncf i believe was founded around 2015
so uh you know we could have ended up
with web native as our term for example
so i don't think it's that bad of a name
now
because wasm is portable
this is what we were kind of thinking
even in 2015 for for the problem that i
was talking about that i was trying to
solve i have an application i have to
deploy to a bunch of different targets
those targets i have to have specific
platform bindings for each one of those
so it's almost like i'm writing my own
little runtime that's specific to my
application on every platform and i'm
compiling to each of those and that's
incredibly expensive and then for each
one of those projects we had separate
teams running each one of them
now what i would love to see
is being able to compile an application
once to webassembly
as as a common
compilation target
and and then have the runtimes be
something that that's sort of managed in
an open way that's common across many
different applications
and so
i told you i was going to give you a
bird's eye view these are supposed to be
eggs
but this is kind of that exact same
diagram but in terms of a matrix because
i think if you're somebody that is
interested in cost you're thinking about
like what is your build matrix what's
your test matrix for all of these
different things that you have to
support
and i think a lot of us have probably
recently felt the pain of having to
support arm
for me it was our container was is x86
and that didn't run on arm at all the
virtualization wasn't working but for
many other people you know it was just
the case that it wasn't as fast and so
you needed to add more to your build
matrix containers did help us with some
portability aspects but
i think really what we would love to see
is kind of the holy grail of having one
egg
solved for each one of our applications
on the server and the browser and in the
edge
this is one other thing that i feel
obligated
to show this is
an oft-quoted tweet from solomon hikes
who's one of the founders of docker and
he said that if wasm and wazi existed in
2008
then
we wouldn't have needed to create a
technology like docker
this ruffled some feathers
and so you might be wondering what is
wazzy well wazzy is
uh
i i think of it as really a part of the
runtime it's a set of interfaces
in some cases posix compatible
interfaces that allow
wasm modules to run well outside of the
browser
but one interesting take that's not just
you know pure posix like we could have
just ported all the posix apis and been
done with it but but that would have
really
broken a lot of the promises of
webassembly the safety security and
portability aspects of that and so
it's capability based by design
and what that means is that
say for example one of the one of the
early things that reported
is being able to access environment
variables and if i wanted to um
have a driver program and has access to
envs then
only a set of the keys that are exposed
to my webassembly instance are available
to me via wazzy
and to compile to wazzy it's it's really
simple you typically in any of your top
level languages you have a top level
target
this case is rust and and you target
wasm 32 wazzy
now it's still early days and so there
are a lot of proposals that are in
flight for this
it's one of the areas that i think
everybody in this room can uh help with
the innovation in the space
um
one other thing that i do mention is
that there is no networking protocol yet
for that's been
approved for wazzy but there's a really
interesting take on this which kind of
pushes
the the work into
the run time via waggy so long as your
runtime is waggy compatible and your
webassembly module meets some of those
contractual pieces then you are able to
do networking style work and i think
we'll get a few more talks about that
today
now
i keep talking about the runtime and and
the reality is is that there are a lot
of them there are 20 plus runtimes that
are out there
there are many different compilers
because working on performance is fun
and uh but more than anything there are
also many different platforms that are
cropping up for webassembly a lot of
these are
really interesting to me personally i
think that they're
new evolutions on new types of computing
paradigms and it's incredibly exciting
as far as languages well there are a ton
of them so i'm not going to list them
all
i think again it's about 20 plus
but
if you have a compound language and
that's your favorite language while
you're in luck it's very likely that
that has already has support for wasm
the reason why i wanted to touch the
slide specifically is because there's
this common misconception that you have
to write and rest to be able to work
with webassembly uh which is kind of
hilarious for me because you know
obviously my original case was c plus
and that's what i've been bringing
forward all along but
i would say even in 2015 cpus plus and c
were still the main things uh that you
were able to use with webassembly
because web assembly and its precursor
asm.js
and and that's largely because
inscription built off of the llvm tool
chain
now obviously rust is is has had uh an
amazing
complement with wasm they've really
grown and supported each other and if
you think about it a lot of the things
that are really nice and rust and a lot
of things that motivate developers to
use rust are really similar motivations
to use webassembly memory safety and
amazing developer tools and portability
but there are going to be other talks
later today that'll cover some of these
other
languages and and
i i just want to see more
i think you know i think we're all
really excited over the past two months
to have seen python and ruby both gain
webassembly support now i added a c in
front of these and that's because it's
taken the c interpreter
and and that piece has been what's been
compiled to webassembly
now there are a few wasm specific
languages like
uh grain and assembly script
for a simple script i'm going to call
that out specifically because it is also
you know you would say an interpreted
language if you're not familiar with
assembly script but you are familiar
with typescript
you'll find using assemblyscript is
really nice because the syntax is very
similar but one key difference is that
assemblyscript is ahead of time compiled
i think that's really compelling and
really interesting very innovative what
we've been seeing is a lot of
interpreters get copaldo asm
and and not a lot of scripting languages
getting ahead of time compilation so i'm
really looking forward to seeing the
innovation that happens in this space
going forward
speaking of innovation what's next well
it's the component model
it this is really a proposal in the
space of wazi it's it's building on top
of some of the other proposals that have
gone through
the idea is that it's a language neutral
approach to building webassembly
applications
and you're able to build them on top of
each other like branches if you thought
i was done with the bird analogies you
don't know me
and so as you're able to build many
different wasm modules on top of each
other uh we can do something that's
really incredible that hasn't been done
before
uh have you ever experienced the
situation where you're you're working at
a company and you know you're mostly
invested in one language
and you go to your boss and you say hey
i found this library it does exactly
what we need i don't have to write all
this code
can we use it and they say well am i
going to have to enable the sego flag
and you say well yeah maybe
and they say no we can't do that let's
let's port it or let's come up with a
different solution maybe something
that's a little bit slower or say you're
working at a java shop and now you're
introducing something that has to
operate over jni in so many cases we're
separated by our language ecosystems
and
more than anything that
silos us as developers in each layer of
our stack
so something like the component model
can really mix things up and change
things for the better so before i was
talking about you know this giant matrix
that you have of applications by you
know by operating
operating systems and targets to just
having one single compilation target
but now imagine
i've really exploded that sandbox right
because now if if things support the
component model we can get to the point
where we have access to millions of
different tools
if that excites you and you find it
interesting i recommend pushing your
company to join the by code alliance
it's pushing that proposal and many
others forward
if you're an individual contributor and
you're interested in working like in the
w3c which is pushing for the webassembly
specification
or you just want to get involved in the
community the place that i linked here
is wasn't builders that's a really great
place to get started
now
we're going to enter a part where i
think is a little bit more of my
opinions of the webassembly landscape
but we'll start with a really simple one
these are terminals that are written in
rust
when something is written in brass it's
sort of a no-brainer to
write
to to make your plug-in model be
something that uses wasm because rest
and wasm are so complementary to each
other
but there are cases that are incredibly
surprising like microsoft flight
simulator is a game and it allows mods
of the game with wasm an older version
of this used dlls
so if you can imagine somebody's able to
hack a game what are they able to do my
to my computer when i install it and
give it full access
but there are also very standard
production examples
i really like the figma example here
because with figma they actually started
with javascript it's really common when
you're saying okay i want to come up
with a plug-in model
you typically are going to look at maybe
lua or javascript or some other
scripting engine and they started with
javascript but due to some security
issues they ended up landing on
webassembly for a sandboxable
capabilities
if you're interested in that i recommend
checking out the their engineering blog
it has a fantastic deep dive
now we're here at cncf so you're
probably already familiar with these two
projects envoy is a side core proxy
there's a cloud native computing
foundation
project called wazim proxy that lets you
extend envoy so that you can write your
own http filters and transformations
but
what i find so interesting about this
case and also in the open policy agent
case where you're able to write custom
policies is that we're really moving it
the computation that you need right next
to where you need to run and and come up
with that decision
i think that's one of the trends that
we're going to start seeing more is near
data processing
and hopefully that gives us better
performance but more than anything it
means that we didn't have to move that
data out over a network request so we're
getting data locality as a bonus now i'm
not an expert in this space but uh
what's been explained to me is that
smart contracts run on the blockchain
and uh once some set of conditions has
been met
the smart contract executes any computer
that's participating on the blockchain
like that could be your own desktop uh
can execute that smart contract that's
got to be safe and secure in sandbox uh
well to me that's a plug-in
and and so all of these so far are
really in my mind different ways of
writing plugins
now a lot of people don't think of data
processing as a plug-in system
but there are several out there already
in my opinion
red panda which is obviously the red
panda here and infineon are both data
streaming
engines and they allow users to pass in
their own transformations of those
engines
and and to basically bring arbitrary
code and run in those systems
the database that i work on is single
store but there are many others that are
finding ways to add user-defined
functions
using webassembly so that we're pushing
that compute down to the data
still a db is one tidb and many others
so this is a term that we're starting to
see crop up more often when people talk
about webassembly and and so this is
like the case that i work on which is
compile your code to asm using you know
whatever language is supported and then
using a single sql statement you say
create function and you pass in your
wasm module maybe over an http url
but what's so interesting about this is
that because we take that wasm module
and we're a distributed database we now
are able to move it across many nodes in
our stack so in a lot of ways this is
another distributed computing problem
but all the properties that make wasm
amazing in the browser like being
lightweight and fast and scalable and
being a very tiny footprint and format
makes it perfect for these types of
distributed computing problems
now i live in north carolina so you
might not know this bird
but he lives in my backyard i took a
picture of him and then i drew this
picture it's called a woodpecker and
he the woodpecker that's in my backyard
is constantly trying to break into my
house and so i thought he was the
perfect analogy for talking about
security
so why is wasm secure well um we already
kind of know some aspects of that wasm
modules only have access to the
interfaces that they've been granted
from the host run time
and they don't trust the code that
they're executing
but
that's not the interesting part here the
interesting part is thinking about all
the trends and pressures that we're
experiencing as an industry and how
that's going to really push people i
believe to wasm the first one being that
software supply chain attacks are
increasing every day
and
finding ways to mitigate
all the different vulnerabilities that
we have across our hundreds of
dependencies for applications is going
to be key
wasm is a really interesting take on
that approach for example
there's a methodology that firefox
employs that is very novel it takes
basically parts of their application
stack compiles those to wasm modules and
then takes those wasm modules and runs
them eventually in machine code so what
it means is that it mitigates entire
swaths of zero-day vulnerabilities for a
single monolithic application so it's
really in my mind taking the way that
you write applications and twisting it
to be sort of like a plug-in model
within your apps
so
by the end of this year the majority of
us
will have uh almost all of our customers
using under some type of privacy law
enforcement
gdpr started it but there have been many
others that have come afterwards
i believe liam's been pushing this idea
several times now i haven't heard a lot
of other people talk about it and i
think it's really key when we think
about
how and where we store our data
with webassembly we are very explicit
about our memory model
and uh who shares
what and and where and so the
capability-based design of wazzy i think
is going to be really key and
considering things like privacy law
so when we think of a new technology
stack
we typically have a set of applications
maybe one or many that are talking to
each other over rest services or some
kind of network
maybe they're hitting ai and ml
inferencing over some type of cred rest
endpoint
they typically have many different
libraries they're connected to many
different data sources
they're running across many different
devices
typically deployed in some type of
orchestration across you know many many
different operating systems in theory so
my question to you is
where
would i write only one language
anywhere in this stack do i expect only
one language to exist ever
probably none of these probably i want
portability in each layer of this stack
obviously everywhere we need safety
security and performance
but when we think about
you know
what are the things that each layer of
the stack actually need we know that we
need many different languages
portability safety security
but also you know just being fast to
download and start because it's not just
one tree it's a forest
now i can't predict the future but to me
when when i look at the modern
technology stack what i'm thinking about
is
how webassembly is going to be at the
top the middle and the bottom of
whatever this new thing is
and because of that
this
it really means that wasm is cloud
native
so let's talk about the next area
with serverless and functions as a
service now
i believe that one of the main reasons
why
this hasn't been as popular as what i
originally expected it to be is because
of cost
at the end of the day we were still
running the same amount of compute and
memory needed to run a specific task
but with wasm we really have an
interesting take on how to vastly reduce
our costs for these cases
so because wasm starts faster than
containers because it's lighter weight
and has a smaller memory footprint
and also because we're we're able to
actually scale it to zero because it is
so fast in many cases and and functions
uh we have to already have some
pre-warmed state of it
so that we're able to service requests
quickly right because containers may
take several seconds to start but
webassembly modules
may take a few milliseconds maybe even
microseconds
but i think more than anything that's
going to push people to to enter our
webassembly landscape is cost
and uh what we know is that the cloud is
expensive it's given us a lot right
we've been able to write in
microservices deploy
faster
independent of each other
but
people aren't going to use our
technology the technologies that we
create
unless it solves problems and one of the
biggest problems in cloud today is cost
so let's talk a little bit about the
future this is completely my opinions
and i'll start with a really aggressive
one which is
is web assembly going to be the next
default compilation target well if you
believe me that it is the last plug-in
model that you'll ever need
then wasm really could be a default
compilation target especially for many
languages obviously the languages that
directly support webassembly
as a first language but i expect many
others
now if you believe that then you might
believe that webassembly
is going to kind of push people to
consider writing applications more like
a plug-in i gave the firefox example
earlier uh but you know in my mind
serverless and fazz are really kind of
an interesting take on what it is to be
a plug-in so
when you're running a fast service or
serverless managed service and you're
accepting other people's code and you're
running it in your infrastructure you
have to make sure that it's sandboxed in
some way and it can't impact other users
to me again that's a plug-in uh so i
think in a lot of these cases when we
start seeing more wasm we'll see kind of
this
i'm considering just an extension of the
plug-in model
and if that's the case
then we know that
you're almost always going to be
guaranteed a web assembly runtime at
every layer of the stack
if you know that then what we're really
talking about in the space of innovation
it's really the future of runtimes as a
whole
and if we're there well
do we have one package manager to rule
them all no
we've been trying that for a long time
we just introduced new ones i don't
expect that to be the case but i do
expect package managers to start serving
webassembly
because other
many of our top-level languages now
support wasm and can pull them in and
link against so
with uh
we're already seeing this really with
npm but i totally expect even in this
year to see several more
so
with the component model we're going to
finally get
universal language and library support
but we'll also see
because of that the democratization of
our software
we will be able to
work with every layer of the stack
because they're able to finally
interrupt between each layer it's no
longer the case that you're a front-end
engineer and you can't use a really
interesting breast library or you're a
systems level engineer and somebody
wrote something in go that you want to
be able to use
you know at a lower level
i think something like this is really
going to make it so that it doesn't
matter who and where you are on your
skills journey you're going to be able
to use the best component and library
and tool for the job
and that's really exciting
and
i think
we're all here today so that we can push
this technology forward and
you know i i really encourage everybody
to to reach out in the community
because you know birds of a feather
flock together thank you
[Applause]